[Music]
how are you guys doing i'm joined with
the esteemed the honorable
and the legendary man zeeshan
from smile to jenna youtube channel
which all of you
must subscribe to how are you doing i'll
handle it i'm good bro
so after all of that you're not going to
give me something back
just give me a minute um there must be
something
how's it going you've been doing a
fantastic job but i think a lot of the
the viewers have already seen you and
ali have been doing i want to make this
very public that you did a really good
job
in the media offensive hunter
bro against the zionist state and i
think
social media is now taking uh the lead
oh for sure it's making a big impact and
this time but we're seeing sky
bbc having to pick up their socks having
to really pick up their act
they're still a bit biased though isn't
it of course oh of course
they're definitely but when we expose it
then they realize oh we need
we need to also focus on that science
narrative becomes
untenable because of social media well
because of media buildings coming down
because of coronaviruses
centers getting born because of little
children it's just becoming
it's too clear now it's too broad
daylight you've got cameras social media
bigger platforms
yeah and muslims have invested time on
these social media platforms there is
bias happening but alhamdulillah i mean
what kind of state i mean
i was just looking at the stats today
with you isn't it and looking at the
ratios what kind of state would continue
punishing children for the actions of
adults like
you know that you're dropping bombs
there's a 30 chance that's going to land
on a child of 200 people that have been
killed
61 have been children in this
to this day right 61 out of 200 and
some some maybe 40 or something that
have been women so that's a 50 chance
you're gonna be hitting women or
children
the rest of them probably civilians how
many hamas are you actually hitting with
these
uh so what what they are effectively
doing is they're punishing children
you know they're punishing hamas
supposedly through
through killing children this is a
disgusting
uh operation and it's targeting
civilians
it is targeting civilians but we want
the reason why i wanted to make a
reaction video today about what the
opinions of um those individuals i live
just general folk is because the hate
has to start from somewhere
and when i watch this kind of social
experiment i thought to myself well this
reminds me of reading old
nazi history there's no doubt about it
in my mind oh damn but i wanted to show
the viewers the extent to which the hate
fills the environment
in this so-called country called israel
so let's get started inshallah with the
reaction video
eons square in jerusalem which the
government has actually declared to
rename
tolerance square and we're just going to
ask everyday israelis what they think
about the situation
you're american where are you from and
why did you come here uh i'm from
new york um and i came here with my
family when i was younger
to make aliyah um because it was always
my parents dream to come to israel
because we're religious so are you
american yes oh cool why
uh when did you move here in white i
moved here 11 years ago
my family moved here because um this is
the country of the jewish people and the
future of the jewish people
and uh we want to be here how old are
you guys 18.
we're 18 years old now we're here in
israel taking a leadership course and
we're going to the army for a few months
to see how life's here
and then we hope to bring back some of
this knowledge to our
youth movements so you're like an
internship with the army
it's about two months and they show you
everything about the army
israel is a great place it's a nice
place you should come and visit
uh like i love israel and i feel safe
here
like is there's not people
in a with knives every day and there's
not
a i don't know people exploding
palestinians yeah
no but pretty much the life here is
really good
for people living here it's just normal
to see people in the army walking around
with guns
and you feel completely safe and
protected i feel like
we know who the threat is and it's not
coming from
anyone random as opposed to in the rest
of the world that could be anyone
here we know we know who our enemy is
and we know that they are out to get us
who is the enemy who's the enemy that's
that's a very good question
i don't think it's specifically any
nation i think
it's the people that um
are so interested in being politically
correct that they won't actually
go after the the people that are trying
to
cover things up i think that that
the islam is uh it's a very bad disease
[Music]
not just for israel it's a disease
that's affected him as well
all around the world we can see
[Music]
a lot of americans don't really
understand what israel is like we hear a
lot of things in the news a lot of
people are sympathizing with the
palestinian plight
um can you talk about what it's like to
kind of live in this situation
uh first of all it's very hard
i also am an urban organization
it's against the jews of the merry arabs
did you say the organization was did
what again
we there goes on the organization is
the the thing of it is to that jews
shall
marry aaron shouldn't marry arabs why do
you feel strongly about that
because jews is a special nation that
god gave it to the jews
and we don't want jews to get mixed up
together with a different nation
i think israelis have to take over
and uh they have to kick them
kick them away it would be much better
not not to kill them just to
not to go back to to arab countries
you can't deal with the story of joseph
you know in the in the quran and the old
testament funny enough
when they were deciding what to do with
him should we kill him should we sorry
i'll just throw him in the well
they're dealing with the arabs like that
with joseph wow
wow they still don't learn their lesson
well this guy hasn't i'm sure he hasn't
let's see what this guy has to say
with these people there's no need to try
there's no need to talk to them what we
can do
is when they they do enough harm we
retaliate that's war and that's the
situation that any jew lives in israel
has to deal with
we have to kill him and not because he's
the arab because he's a terrorist
i mean if you wanted to see if you
wanted to see how nazis
would be in the 21st century this is a
good uh
this is honestly this is how it would be
this is a good good case study i would
say yeah i believe this is how they must
have been speaking about the jews in
germany
all that's happened now you just replace
the word jewish with arab
and german jew sorry jewish with german
and arab with jew
and you've got the same situation in the
1930s there's no difference ah i
i genuinely see no difference at all
between what's going on here
and what we probably would have
witnessed in the 1930s in germany
think about that for a second if you
would have asked the average
german okay in a city center
where there was support for hitler you
would expect there to be a lot of
support
for anti-semitism and a lot of support
for aryan
supremacy this is the same thing but
just reversed different nations
different ethnicities it's fascism it is
racism it is ethnocentrism
and it is exactly what i mean this is
what i don't like i mean
if those individuals those particular
individuals were to be asked about the
holocaust
they would call it all those things we
just talked about and then they're
perpetrating themselves
victims of the holocaust have now become
perpetrators of another holocaust
absolutely
genocide what a shame and you know what
indeed not all jews or israelis feel
like that but here
you have a seemingly
independent third party going around
asking israel to speak candidly
and and that's what they're doing and
we're seeing a worrying trend here
absolutely also kick out the family
because it's all begins with
uh you know i would say education
what are they taking the kids the kids
it does you know it's families
i may think that we need to
[Music]
foreign really well i i think we should
give them a country
if you're doing any problem you're just
going there to give them a country and
then it's going to be a
war between countries you know if
they're going to rockets we're going to
throw one big one and done
i don't think there's any answer there's
only one way
like i would carpet bomb them you would
have to wow
it's the only the only way you could
deal with it yeah they put them in the
gas chamber
yeah try
[Music]
you mean all arabs or gaza or
i i believe that they
like i hope to believe they're they're
not but i do think they are because
i do think wow i never i don't
i don't trust them you can't trust them
but you know you know
the only the only way is that to stop it
completely
but now what you see in the flesh
[Music]
[Laughter]
there is also uh jewish civilian
civilians that ate arabs yeah i'm not
saying
but we have also people that like the
arabs and everything like
small anime i think another thing that
the jews should have
rights to hate them i think we have the
right
to aid them i don't know right why not i
i want to trust
so just seeing this is like a case study
example a small sample group
as it may be right but i've shown this
and if you if you want more information
about actual studies that have been done
uh you can look at my refutation of ben
shapiro when we actually put
uh facts like um surveys have been done
on peace index surveys
which shows how rampant racism
islamophobia anti-arab sentiment
anti-black sentiment there is in this
so-called nation called israel
and i just think it's shocking
considering the histories of the jewish
people with the holocaust
that they are for all intents and
purposes just replicating the behavior
and the attitudes and the ideologies of
the nazis
to a group of people who they think that
they are
basically masters over who are the arabs
and just not the arabs as we've
mentioned all the other ethnic groups
they think that they are the chosen
the the the center of attention and the
the best people that there are because
of
their ethnicity because of the accident
of birth
and i think as muslims we may not have
the media representation
that's why people are able to come up
with this rhetoric
that oh it's muslims that are preaching
hating them addresses
in their holy books and this and that
but if you look yes the media may not
center that much on judaism
if you see some of the stuff that's done
here even in london
yeah in uh in gold is green and uh
some yeah some of the uh the practices
that take place they have their own
ambulances they have their own uh
syllabus yeah obviously power to them
and we haven't got an issue with that
but what we do have a problem with is
racism but we
we have an issue when they come and when
muslims try to make some progress
yes and then they say oh you guys are
doing this in your schools oh you get
special treatment over here
i'm sorry if you you can't
give one group preference over the other
and
whilst you know uh smashing the the
other group just because they don't have
enough media representation
and here stuff like this you will not
see as much
no you don't see us this doesn't serve
any geopolitical interests
that's the bottom line at the end of the
day as joe biden said himself and
perhaps you can do a video just on this
he said if there wasn't in israel we'd
need to make one oh damn
he said that he said if there wasn't in
israel the middle east would have to
make one
meaning israel serves a geopolitical
function
for the americans and therefore go
opposing it makes no political sense and
that's why
whether democratic or republican
american presidents have a history
of supporting the state the corrupt
state of israel
and they will continue doing so because
it serves the geopolitical
objectives of the united states of
america whereas
it may serve the geopolitical interest
of
the united states of america if they
were to
put muslims and islam in a bad light
because it gives them the option to
foreign
invade the the country and take it for
its assets and
its uh natural resources that's what
we've been seeing in the last
50 years definitely definitely
i guess we'll leave it there so jazakum
guys
thanks so much for watching it was a
pleasure doing this with you zeeshan
thanks so much pleasure thanks for
having me bro
and you know guys make sure that you
spread these videos
far and wide because we're sure we need
to make as much noise as possible
uh for this particular course a hundred
percent
because the more you start raising
videos like this it will encourage other
people to speak out
yes yeah the more you're liking the more
you're sharing normalizing yeah
yeah yeah you've got pogba coming out
you've got um
john oliver you've got philip defranco
these are all the mainstream people be
youtubers there you've got um that that
tan
desai or whatever his name is a sikh
politician you've got
the the the usual suspects like jeremy
corbyn and
you know you've got a lot of people
standing up mobilizing
yeah people probably didn't even know
about illbit at the arms company located
in leicester and there's protests
happening there as well
yeah and there's uh you know al jazeera
they're there
their towers being knocked down with
alongside
yeah alongside uh associated press
and the likes so uh also people are
literally there
and you can see that unarmed yeah these
are medical personnel they are media
personnel
this footage of uh army uh or police
about about about to throw
their tear gas and then the camera as
soon as the camera is there oh the guy
just holds it back
so you've probably seen a lot of these
videos so the more you do it
the more it will encourage other
influencers to also do that because you
have to understand that for some
influence
it is about feeding the algorithm
getting the views getting the money and
if they're seeing that look it's it's
working here
it's it's good you know i'm saying like
some people do need that
dunya kind of
we hope so anyway and we're going to be
spreading these videos
and we're going to be providing the
thorn in the throat
of the zionist state of israel oh damn
[Music]
islamic
you